the sexual assault accusations against
Supreme Court nominee Brett Kavanaugh
started in national conversation about
the reliability of past memories in a
recent New York Times op-ed a Weill
Cornell psychiatrist writes quote
neuroscience research tells us that
memories formed under the influence of
intense emotion are indelible in the way
that memories of a routine day or not
Kavanagh has denied all allegations of
sexual assault dr. Ted Huey is a
professor of psychiatry and neurology at
Columbia University he joins us to
explain how the memory works and the
impact of trauma good morning to you dr.
Hugh good morning thanks for having me
we're glad you're here help us
understand this because what does the
research show when it comes to memory
and trauma well I agree with the doctor
that you had just mentioned there
there's a misconception that emotion and
trauma is bad for memory that you don't
remember things in those situations when
actually the way our brain tags what's
important to be remembered is emotion
and actually the hippocampus and
amygdala two areas involved in memory
and emotion are very close to each other
and it's your brains way of saying this
is very important remember it and so you
know as an example of that you probably
couldn't tell me what you were doing the
morning of September 8th 2001 but I'm
sure you could tell me what you were
doing the morning of September 11th 2001
which was a very emotionally charged day
for all of us can two people be at the
same have the same incident but have
different memories and both be telling
the truth very much so so you know just
as the example I gave you a non
emotional or non emotionally charged
incident is less memorable usually and
so if two people come into a situation
and for one it's a very emotionally
charged event for the other person it's
not often you'll get a situation years
later where the person for whom it was a
charged event will say well I remember
that day vividly or that event vividly
and the other person will say I've no
memory of that
can you tell us what's happening in the
brain during one of these emotionally
charged moments literally what's
happening so yes so your amygdala which
is a structure that's very important for
emotional processing is telling your
hippocampus flag this this is important
you know so that we can hopefully you
know ideally evolutionarily avoid this
situation in the future
so it's being flagged as a very
important thing now at the same time
when you're in a highly emotional state
you're not sitting calmly rationally
saying well I'm going to remember this
and I'm going to remember that so what
you end up happening is this situation
which is
and described by trauma survivors or
people after very emotional events where
they have very vivid memories but
strange memories so they'll say like
what I remember the the sweater my
attacker was wearing but I can't
remember his face or you know or I
remember you know the smell but I don't
remember the make of the car and that's
because we even though the memories are
very vivid and your memories actually
turned up very high you know there to
remember events you're not kind of
thinking calmly and rationally about
what I want should remember what I
shouldn't remember so how reliable is
the memory after a traumatic event
decades later yeah and that's a that's a
question that's obviously come up a lot
and you know I think one one principle
about that is it's hard to give a kind
of blanket reliability so what the
research shows is that that it matters
kind of what you're talking about so
that you know more peripheral memories
might be miss remembered as the decades
go on but usually the core is remembered
pretty well so an example would be if
you're mugged you might kind of miss
remember whether it was on 61st Street
or 62nd Street if I ask you 20 years
later you're not gonna forget that you
were mugged so you know it's so when you
talk about an accuracy of an old memory
what are you talking about it you're
talking about the core event or are you
talking about the kind of mortar you
would remember it better especially if
you told that story over and over again
over the years that's true although you
know you have to be careful of that
because memory you know people another
misconception people have is that memory
is like a videotape it's a it's a really
all memory whether traumatic memory or a
non traumatic memory are fragments
our pieces we remember and then we kind
of turned it into a narrative afterwards
sometimes that narrative can have
inaccuracies that then become through
repeated retelling kind of embedded but
but you know usually the elements of it
or them are the memories we use to
structure that memory really interesting
thank you very thank you for having me
no thank you we appreciate that yeah